Theme park rides are undeniably fun.
Elevated swing lovers will be delighted with a new attraction...
...at the Six Flags Over Texas amusement park in Arlington.
Called the Texas SkyScreamer, riders sit in chairs and enjoy the sights...
...while being swung in circles.
The feature has been declared the world's highest swing ride.
It stands 400 feet tall.
The gondola measures 124 feet in width, and it's capable of twirling passengers...
...at speeds up to 35 miles per hour.
Offering panoramic views of major sports stadiums and cityscapes,...
...the swing is able to hold a maximum of 24 people for each run.
The park president stated,...
..."We are thrilled to add the tallest swing ride in the world...
...to our premier lineup of rides and attractions.
It offers the most unique ride experience for an attraction of this kind,...
...and also lives up to the Texas mantra...
...that "Everything is bigger in the Lone Star State."
The Texas SkyScreamer will be open until August 25th.
Are you up for it?